so just like yesterday what I'm gonna
try and focus on on is you getting your
hands on this skill and being confident
in doing them so this set of steps is
actually really really simple in fact
really there's only one thing that you
need to do but this is just trying to
break it down a little bit for you okay
so if you ain't given a quadratic
equation like this we could represent it
with a graph you've looked at some of
this before but two reasons why we look
at this again number one we're going to
increase the complexity of the quadratic
equations you're going to graph and
secondly I'm going to talk about a few
things that we haven't seen before with
a relation to quadratics so in order to
get there we want to review what it
looks like before hand okay so step one
this is really is the main step have a
look at this and find your intercepts
there are two kinds what are they x and
y how do you find x-intercepts
what do you let you let y equal zero and
if you want to find y-intercepts you let
X equal zero so it's a bit funny that
those are backwards but we can do both
of these and find out where our graph
intersects with the axes so let's do
that really quickly let's find the
intercepts so for x intercepts I'm going
to let y equal 0 which gives me what
this equation up here the left-hand side
just becomes 0 that's it now in order to
actually get something meaningful out of
this we then have to use all the skills
we've been demonstrating with
factorizing these quadratics and so on
and finding solution see this is what
you're doing in questions 2 & 3 of the
review I noticed it's a little bit
awkward having all these negative signs
around especially at the front so I'm
actually going to multiply everything by
negative 1 what happens when you
multiply 0 by negative 1
still just 0 right but then all of these
guys all of the signs change so I get 2x
squared there I get plus 3x and then I
get a minus 9
okay can we factorize this a pair of
numbers that adds two three multiplies
to negative 18 can you think of the pair
of numbers negative 3 and positive 6
that'll do the job Waner 2x squared we
said negative 3 and positive 6 so I've
broken it apart now I'm going to pair
things up okay so let's have a look here
what's the common factor between these
two it's just X that's it so I'll take
that out and then I'll write what's left
behind have a look at the next pair
what's the common factor 3 so I take
that out and then I see what's left
behind which because I did things right
we did things right you gave me the
right pair of numbers it lines up that
looks good so now my final line 0 equals
this okay now this is why it's so
helpful to write something like this up
the front you've gone all through this
mental effort to write all this down
you're like why did you do that again
and the answer was you're looking for X
intercepts
you'll get one here and one here what do
you get from the first one negative 3
that's one of your x-intercepts and look
carefully positive 3 over 2 should do it
right because the twos will cancel leave
you 3 minus 3 oh that's good so 3 over 2
okay so just keep that in your hat x
equals that x equals that those are your
X intercepts right let's find the y
intercept it's actually a lot easier y
intercepts to find that as you told me
before I'm gonna let X equal 0 okay so I
can put x equals 0 into any of these
spots whoops
wish sorry any of these spots here so
which is the most appropriate one I
think the very first line would work
right because you get y equals what's
this become when x is 0
what's this become with x0 there are and
you just get left with the nine okay
in fact just as a side note you don't
have to write this down but you know
when we wrote in straight lines that y
equals MX plus B do you remember what
the B was the M is the gradient but the
B is just the y-intercept it's just that
number well here this guy here that's
the y-intercept everything else just
vanishes okay so therefore y equals nine
that's my y-intercept okay now draw for
me because we're about to plot this is
step two draw for me a Cartesian plane
but just think for a second don't just
draw it randomly think about the numbers
you're gonna have there right see how
I'm gonna have a negative value and a
positive value for X so I need the whole
thing this nine is quite high so I want
to make sure that it goes high up enough
okay so I'm going to draw something like
this
okay one step at a time my x-intercepts
negative 3 and positive 3 on 2
so I'm going to put a decent scale on
here let's make that 1 2 3 so let's call
that guy negative 3 and I put a big fat
dot to indicate I'm going to go through
that if that was 1 2 3 then 1 2 3 3 on 2
is right in there halfway so I'm gonna
label that and it's 3 or 2 ok I need to
go up to 9 for my Y value so I'm gonna
go 1 2 3 4 that's too small so I'm gonna
go double 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 there we go
remember your X and your Y axes don't
have to have the same scale as each
others so long as they are the same on
the of them their own axis right so this
X here 3 over there has to be the same
as 3 over here but this guy I can make
is tall or as short as I like okay
fantastic
now I'm almost there I want to do this I
want to plot these and I know what kind
of shape I'm going to get out of this
it's gonna be a have a look can you join
the dots you're going to get this up and
down kind of figure right in fact you
can roughly down join the dots and you
should get something like that
ok now you may recall the place where
that parabola turns around so yeah it's
going up and then it goes down it has a
special name did it remember starts with
a V it's the vertex now a question I
have for you is how did I know the
vertex of the parabola was on this side
and not on this side how did I know
that's where it would go up how did I
know that that wasn't the vertex or that
the vertex wasn't over here any
suggestions the vertex it's and again
are you asking blankly ok you're going
to find the vertex right
smack bang in the middle of the parabola
that's because it's on the axis of
symmetry every parabola is symmetrical
so in fact if you have another color I'd
love you to draw a vertical maybe dyed
line that goes right through the vertex
like this so you can work out where your
axis of symmetry is for starters you can
work it out just by measuring right you
can see where minus 3 is you can see
where 3 on 2 is just put it halfway
between and you will find the axis of
symmetry okay now step 3 this last part
here it says use more features if
necessary this is why you know how we
got our solutions out of this right how
many solutions did we get you got yeah
you got 2 for the X's and then you got 1
for the Y ok
you always get a y-intercept this is a
bit interesting
you always get one of these but you
don't always get x-intercepts you don't
always get solutions to this ok that's
tricky sometimes you don't get any
x-intercepts or sometimes you just get
one or sometimes you get two so if you
don't get one of those or any of those
you don't have enough information so you
have to use more features you have to
plot more points you have to choose
other values and then see where does
this shape trace through we're going to
talk in the next exercise 1107 about how
to find the axis of symmetry when you're
like I don't know where to look
we'll wait until the next time I go to
teach you that ok